jack-jack an object came down in 1:7 got  it on my way  sixty years ago verse was attacked we  won the war but they destroyed half the  planet everyone's been evacuated nothing  human remains  our job is security in drone maintenance  where the mapa  two weeks Jen then we can be even join  the other side doesn't seem right  we won the war now we have to leave  this is Mission Control how y'all doing  this morning don't tailor chances  dangerous down there  I've been watching you jack who are you  the people you work for lie to me  I told you to follow for us  and soon you would join the others it's  time to know the truth how do you know  my name  you're still an effective team survivors  weren't you telling me who are you  help us  you don't have to die  have to die  it's time to them home I'm not gonna do  that it's my home